this is a production of Cornell
University
so so this afternoon we were part of
this is I've got 29 advisees and AG
science I got moved to development
sociology and while I enjoy my twelve my
sociology home Hort and sips is where I
started out and have style connection
too so this is part of the process of
Miri of applying back for joint
membership between d social and sips and
as it was I just presented a variation
of this college and I never got a chance
to do this to my colleagues here within
sips or development sociology just to
get a little bit of a feel for what I
spend a fair amount of my interest and
time doing both through the courses that
I teach but a lot of the time beyond
that in advising and advising outside of
the college is trying to recruit
educators if for New York State
specifically but I'll show you some
statistics related to the interest and
demand for where we're doing also
cultivating connections I don't I found
out my only plan is my mic working it is
all right in it my only plant tie is my
Christmasy Hot Chili Peppers so I pulled
my Cowan out because I do the plant one
was a little thin and I decide it was
time for tie I really what am I going to
do is focus a little bit on a background
for where agricultural education is I'm
really talking there's there's certified
K through 12 but we typically teach six
to six through 12 I do have one young
lady who just started recent if a
college grad is now teaching first and
second grade as part of a rotation so
we're gaining traction in actually using
that K through six piece we spend most
of our time focusing it in the high
school and really doing two different
things
as a general background we really are
stem approach the a either includes
agriculture or arts depending on who you
want to talk to my art teacher who was
across the hall for me we used to argue
back and forth because the a sense
either way but it's very stem focused it
is very much focusing on literacy and
career
centered elements so part of that is
taking high school students getting them
into the community or into the month
elementary and just doing some general
awareness of the broad spectrum of
agriculture including plants and animals
and our interactions that's part of what
horticulture and sips but horticulture
especially is very engaged in that human
component of Ag and that really relates
very carefully to AG education
it's part of what we do is a regular
part of the process its first get them
aware of the details and then realize
how we work with it and part of that
process is very career-driven the idea
they're usually with us at the bot that
bottom bullet they're here usually in
three or four courses the idea is to
share them not all of them go into
agriculture but they gain an awareness
and you would be surprised how many of
them find out that in their career
agriculture will touch them somewhere in
the process that's half the fun is
realizing that what we do really does
impact the larger number of folks even
if they're trying not trying to actually
work in it we all eat we all want qual
high-quality food we like the plants and
the flowers related landscaping all of
that brings Ag in our lives every day
and this is the fun part of getting the
kids excited about it
for a slide that shows up here a little
later from the state's perspective it's
basically that's a newer term for
vocational education so it falls within
the realm of technology it actually also
usually gets house next to the arts
music art technology business and
agriculture they're all electives and
there is a pathway four to five years
we'll give them a CTE endorsement on
their diploma doesn't really do anything
for them one more color but there's a
straight format and that there's a whole
group of CTE based organizations of
which FFA is one of them yeah yeah so it
really is a categorization from the
state education we're very much project
an inquiry based in the approach
learning dr. Noah and I were just
talking about the the shift with some
inquiry and active learning here on
campus as well
these students start out with that
walk in the door it's basically how we
also survive as instructors because if
we get them active and engaged they like
to come to our classes because some of
our poor academic class instructors
don't engage quite as much in that
project and increase perspective
definitely the the encouraging student
diversity and curiosity is really
oriented to the broad spectrum of
Agriculture as a whole and the cultural
impacts of that we're still that's as a
organization we're still growing in that
actually there's a slide that shows up a
little later we're very much in a rural
settings we're still working on the
urban setting is a low gaining traction
to that but it's an area of emphasis
nationally for Ag educators is that
trying to develop the rich connection of
Agriculture into the culture wherever we
happen to be it is based on a national
standards format so this is a it's from
the I didn't put the citation here
there's a citation on the last page the
agricultural national agriculture
council basically oversees the
development of the national AG and food
and natural resources standards all
programs and then in the country should
reference these eight career clusters we
don't use them all to the same degree
but inside of that is a very large
document that sets all these sub set
standards so we can base that we can
meet the needs of our administrators and
say hey here are the specific items that
we're working with but they fall within
those general topics
I mean agribusiness is really
cross-cutting all our areas
biotechnology both animal and plant
related is not quite as strongly
developed environmental science is very
very large fruit processing continues to
grow but it gives us a lot of room to
play as instructors we can play in all
these individual sandboxes and that's
half the fun is to get students prepared
for walking into one of those and they
may not have a whole lot of background
in that they have to basically learn
really fast to get the kids excited
about it
one element that that ties into part of
the reason that I spend a fair amount of
my time recruiting and and trying to
develop program teachers ready to enter
the program coming out of Purdue this
was this is about a 2013 or 2014
projection projects that over the next
five years there's about 60,000 new jobs
in agriculture across the board and
right now that I didn't put the other
part up the statistic coming out of
college colleges four-year degrees in Ag
is about 35,000 graduates so there's a
huge disparity related to that and
basically that spins into AG education
in a high school level is it's still a
very strong area to get students
interested in going into as a career
they may not think about it at first but
when you start looking at the breadth it
gets exciting because there very few
things one of my the best stories I used
to do with seventh and eighth graders is
challenge them to give me a job that I
couldn't attach to agriculture and be a
player yeah you're playing on hardwood
that's all forced you got to do it on
any any type of athlete in most cases
were natural turf back in the dark ages
now it's called astroturf but there's
still an agricultural component to that
perspective and it was a lot of fun to
try to have them challenged where our
career possibilities were and I could
spin all of them back to you at least
some broad spectrum of agriculture and
then as part of this
we've got more job openings and
qualified graduates and again that's
part of what we do in Ag education at
the high school level is Drive them or
encourage them to go towards that
thought process for their future career
outside of high school and the the other
thing that we're I guess this also is a
launching point for we've seen a rapid
growth at least in New York State we're
finding a very rapid growth in those
high school programs when I started
teaching a long time ago
coming up on it's coming up on 25 27
years ago they were losing programs by
about 15 or 18 across the state when I
was trying to get a job so I stayed in
Virginia and taught for two years and
then was able to move back up north now
we've got seven to eight openings that
we don't have certified teachers for
we've got an import from other states or
higher on
of uncertified teachers that they can
then get certified so that the there's a
couple reasons we'll talk about it on
the later slide that I think the
momentum has sincerely changed even at
the high school level of how we think
about agriculture which is encouraging
for somebody who spent their career in
it
past and present it really bases off of
a nineteen seventeen Smith Hughes at our
extension and outreach class this is
really both 4-h and FFA started in that
general concept of the act where we
needed more agriculturalists the farmers
weren't paying attention to our land
grant individuals we found the kids were
a good conduit to get more information
to the the home farms so the Smith
Hughes that was that was part of that
process in the FFA and 4-h evolved in a
couple different areas the two stemming
from that particular legislation we've
got about eight hundred thousand
students across the country to
participate and then I just grabbed two
resources from New York State so we've
got about five billion in New York as of
2016 our agricultural products were at
five billion and in 2014 we had thirty
five thousand farms I should and all of
you I'm talking to the choir in this
case where if we break that out we've
got a large portion of the large volume
and some large farms and a whole lot of
smaller operations I just visited one of
my former students who still make up
he's at seventy-five cows and actually
cash flowing at a slightly positive even
with the poor milk prices although he's
had some stressors in part of the
process but it's it just shows the
strength of agriculture New York and
it's encouraging that more and more
folks are starting to realize that even
without us being quite as direct I've
got administrators in schools that are
starting to pay attention to that growth
of New York again so this is just the
statistical piece of of where we're
starting to see in the state we've got
207 active Agra programs with about
10,000 students in a just in New York
State that's literally 303 teachers
exactly although we may have gained one
since the since I got this data from
Cherry we're figuring 12 chapters per
year in the past three years which is
huge girls compared to a long period of
time where bird didn't have any I'm
really but I'm building that off of the
next last bullet is a Harvard study
pathways to prosperity which really
basically challenged everybody in the in
the high school range of education that
their career orientation was portable
marginal and really argued that if you
want the students to be successful have
some form of career orientation they did
when I was a in middle school that was a
huge push and then it kind of gravitated
away everything in the education system
is cyclical by about five years and we
were running a very poor cycle that
started the push and I really think the
schools have shifted their thoughtful
thoughts regarding career orientation
that is improve their interest in having
the discussions the other piece that
starts to happen where is the visible
success of FFA and 4-h youth in
transitioning from the that childhood to
adulthood the first time they see a four
I'm gonna throw 4-h in there as well
because I have the same the same benefit
in even in Cortland you if you have a
young individual from high school walk
in and give a formal presentation in FFA
they'll wear their official dress so
it's basically coat and tie and they
command a command the presence of the
room quite well they practice that
they're well polished the answer
questions really well and the school
start to realize wait wait how'd you get
that level of participation in your
school and they want the FFA and they
want the leadership development that
that comes from that the only way to do
that is to build it into enough age to
an agricultural program you can't just
have a club it's embedded which is a
slightly slide later on and that's
gained some growth we are I've got a
we've got 51 percent which has grown in
the last sense since this growth we've
actually crossed the fifteen percent
tile in rural schools across the state
and we're at seven percent of urban
schools were in the process I mean
that's a huge area of growth I just got
a note from an experienced teacher who's
now teaching just took a job in Harlem
teaching urban agriculture at an
elementary school
they just created a program for her she
actually she was much she's that
probably older than I am but is
returning back to the classroom but
we're gaining we've got a lot of
potential growth in that urban area
schools and we're making huge strides
I've got one suburban school outside of
Syracuse and then another one local
school in Cortland they've actually got
the funding and are ready to go they
just need to figure out where the
teachers coming from and they'll start
the program and it's from this behind
the scenes they start to see the FFA and
4-h experiences they attach that in the
school systems it's FFA driven and they
started asking good questions and the
momentum continues to grow if we can
keep the teachers this is a traditional
three circle model for education by
Constitution by its establishment at the
national level for Ag education the
Constitution includes three different
components you've got typical classroom
environment you've got a the work
experience sort of required to have a
work experience piece which is out of
the school or even in the school in some
form of paid or even if it's unpaid they
have to track the hours of a work
experience so they get the work the soft
skills and showing up on time
responsibility for the response for
their duties and also the FFA peach
piece which is leadership development
and focused on personal growth those
three pieces have to be offered in some
variation we build heavily off the
classroom the FFA is very strong across
the country and you have a little bit of
ebb and flow across chapters how strong
that surfaces this area is actually in a
reboot so we're actually regaining some
strength and SAE from a new curriculum
that developed but those three pieces
all the students have by the time they
graduate from high school what's great
about that like an ID is that it relates
to the students that walk in the door
here a sample of add courses offered in
New York State and it's this is a fairly
small sampling I should have pulled my
other one when I was teaching when I was
in western New York I thought about 22
courses in rotation a lot of them were
semester long and every three years I
basically rotate through and start over
again but there was enough interest in
those
specific they were sure they were much
more precise some of these are a little
large in terms of topic plant science
and horticulture is this huge spectrum
horticulture we can narrow down to the
plant side I did a landscaping or a
hardscaping course which was landscaping
without the plants where he did stone
work you did patios you did deck
construction that type of thing
a lot of animal science and best science
built in with it with a common thread
also in environmental science and
mechanics so it's it's really the animal
and appliance are the core for the
majority of schools I would like the
mechanics to be a third pillar but a lot
of this the students the teachers don't
have the training and mechanics so
that's gotten a little bit harder to
work with and then AG business really
underlies everything that we talked
about across the process a couple I
thought as I was watched looking at
these photos that the nice thing about
this is I've got a snarky comment in
another slide at least we've got several
the top left and the bottom right here
are plant science driven middle is food
science which is still really into what
we do got an embryology project here top
right a little bit of welding oh yeah
let me before we keep going I do want to
show there's a three-minute clip that
gives you a pretty interesting snapshot
from the teachers perspective what
happens each day I'll see if it will pop
up even their irresponsible cultural
education it's science
hands-on experience environmental topics
technology and everything in between get
your hands dirty in a barn in the lab or
in the shop take classes geared towards
what you want to do and be engaged in
almost anything but sitting through
another PowerPoint see the function of
each part of a cow's stomach by actually
dissecting a digestive tract investigate
how an engine works by tearing a lawn
tractor apart visual
how bacteria are used to produce your
food by conducting experiments in a
science lab is it more than you expected
this is just the beginning after you've
mastered your favorite concepts in the
classroom
let your competitive side take control
participate in events that will help
prepare you for a successful lifelong
career judge livestock
create flower arrangements present a
research project or measure a tree in
student-centered career development
events work hard offer the hopes to win
a trip to the national FFA Convention
held in Louisville Kentucky while you're
there take advantage of being one of
over half a million FFA members that is
develop yourself serve others and
realize what true passion is as you are
surrounded by your best friends in blue
corduroy classy we know but it's been a
tradition and a sign of excellence for
80 years and it's not about to change
anytime soon FFA is the perfect place to
achieve the level of recognition you
deserve from your hard work in your area
of interest as the largest intra
curricular youth organization in the
world
your FFA experiences will prepare you
for and connect you to outstanding life
opportunities have fun outside the walls
of the school when you get the
opportunity to serve agricultural
education and FFA involvement takes you
into the community doing community
service projects well being engaged and
active in your community surrounded by
your friends make connections with local
employers and other rock stars in your
community that can prove beneficial
later in life now let's not forget the
room for financial gain agricultural
education classes set you up with an
individual project or work experience
that allows you to be recognized for
your efforts and nine chances out of 10
you're already working on something that
will work as a project for agricultural
education however by joining an RN class
you gain the potential to be recognized
at the local state and national level
with awards and the chance to win some
pretty hefty cash prizes don't just
think outside the box
imagine education without a box when you
enter into agricultural education the
opportunities are limitless and the
excitement is never-ending but only come
if you have prepared with the time of
your life
[Music]
okay it just gives a quick snapshot of a
whole lot of different visible points
and it's rather than trying to all have
a couple pictures so building off of
that one of the this is a somebody McGee
an FFA basically has an active
relationship and is very well funded
through Agra markets here in New York
this was this is our larger I guess this
is this is six hundred thousand members
nationwide a little couple more stats
just in terms of one hundred nine
chapters in New York State all this was
pulled from an earlier slide because
we've bumped up recently from that and
really they get to know that the
political process as part of what we do
in agriculture because a lot of his
trigger to state national funding so
that's part of what we do local story so
Lindsey just graduated from here she
came in and know here and I stole this
this was I think provided from her
advisor on a slide set that I admit was
creating from she was she transferred in
from Morrisville I believe and wanted to
be a vet and figured quickly turned out
that that animal science at that level
wasn't quite what she wanted to do
she's now graduated Cornell and is in
Ithaca College with the expectation to
start teaching about July first this
time shall it well she'll the job by
April probably and start teaching in
July and I've got several students in
animal science that that kind of see the
light that science isn't quite what they
want to do and they transition into
teaching and that really I've got
another young lady who just graduated
started a brand new program at Geneva
one year in they're hiring a second
teacher because she's had so much
success in that City School District
that they've gone and found a second
teacher these are a couple slides from
most of these have Lindsey anims she was
a state officer when she was in high
school so a couple different experiences
of their officer team just in terms of
some community development they do a lot
of community outreach both with state
level organization as well as the local
chapters
a couple there's this was one of those
that the oddball things that don't quite
fit in terms of details there is Don was
asking you about certification at state
level there is a CT certification that
you can achieve as a school program that
does allow you for an extra endorsement
on the students diploma there typically
is what I've noticed from teaching is
the students that walk into the program
if they get hooked into something in
agriculture they really are excited
about they'll survive English and math
and social studies because they go to
class each day to have one actually a
couple kids that have great mechanics
but really struggled in English and math
and they got through English of math
because they could come down at least
once during the day and just be in a
comfort zone and learn what they wanted
to learn but it helped them get through
the process hands-on inquiry and base
learning on a regular basis you saw a
lot of the images are very much engaged
there's still technical background
behind that but part of the process is
is learning by doing is one of the
underlying mottos of the FFA there's a
lot of college credits that of course
don't apply to Cornell there are several
programs that will develop college
credits through their agriculture
programs either through SUNY Morrisville
or SUNY Cobleskill so depending on the
path they go they can they can start out
with a fair amount of college credits as
long as they don't go here flexible
Sciences a lot of them I was teaching a
food science and environmental science
and there was a third one that was
science credit for the high school so
they didn't have to take biology
chemistry and physics although I
encouraged them to do that they could
also take an agriculture class and get
science credit for their agriculture
classes do you notice that we didn't
talk a lot about a lot of travel
opportunities each year they'll get to
go to a couple statewide events plus the
national convention and travel just
there or they go to summer camp and they
start to intersect the network at a very
young age so in high school by the time
they graduate high school
irregardless of Lindsay who is a state
officer they've got a small network of
folks they know from across the state in
some cases the country that they then
start intersecting with the college
level so it really starts that network
early the community involvement is
something I didn't talk about quite as
much the slide showed a little better
for that very involved
in active participation that each
chapter is really developed from the
needs of the community so there's going
to be some customization it's not a
cookie patent cookie cutter pattern that
fits in every school they really design
what's needed in that area because it is
and totally an elective if the students
aren't taking it and the parents don't
want students to take it it will fold
and we won't have programs a lot of
school pride and I think that's true of
most schools but the FA care individuals
have a tendency to be very very
supportive and develop a really good
strong community culture and with a 350
thousand grant and this year's budget
for new and existing chapters that
actually was an incentive grant this is
the third year I believe we're new chap
new programs get a little bit of a bump
in resources so they can buy some new
equipment and really establish a
stronger program thanks to the governor
putting it into their budget role mr.
corn rental I didn't shut this year but
the last time I checked nine to ten
percent between nine and ten percent of
FFA freshmen either have or Cornell
freshman year had for EHR F a background
its yeah cows cows Frenchmen not Cornell
Cal's freshmen either had FFA or 4-h in
their back down I also find that AG
literacy and career focus it just as a
natural fit for them to sweep into
Cornell the other benefit is the SUNY
program SUNY Cobleskill and SUNY
Morrisville a little bit of SUNY can are
also seeing growth as well as I don't
know if Alfred State has changed their
name back to SUNY Alfred or not they
seem to be going through some
interesting name updates those three
what we used to call the AG and textile
now pull the skill and Morrisville are
doing four year programs so they start
to compete to a degree with Cornell
they're seeing an increase in
participation as well their attendees
the number of people that are trying to
get into the agricultural components of
Morris will Cobleskill and alfred
continue to grow a Cobleskill seen some
drop in its general applications but not
it's AG applications so as a whole is a
really positive time to be a part of
agriculture and I and they still even
when I talk to faculty at Cobleskill
there is an encouragement it's a smaller
No
they'll encourage a certain number to
continue on to Cobleskill or to Cornell
rather than stay all four years at coma
scale there's a little bit of a push and
pull we'll see where that how that
develops what we do continue to get
transfers from the Keoghan techs and
really developing incoming students so
if you've got some 4hf of a background
they'll walk in the door with at least a
little bit of Ag literacy and are ready
to move forward these from my
perspective a little faster than some
that didn't have that background and I
really think that that's a it's going to
continue to grow cuz I've got in two
weeks I've got 200 students coming back
on campus for a Leadership Conference
and part of that process is so they get
exposure to the campus a lot of the
teachers or Cornell grads so they get to
tell some stories and get them excited
about Cornell and just to make them
aware that it's a possibility and they
the financial aid discussion is always
fun to have because if they're in
agriculture already Cornell supports
that quite strongly because they think
the sticker price is too high it's been
nice where the teachers will also
support them to say at least give it a
consideration for those students that
are really really excelling my one
snarky comment is plant science is a lot
of fun to teach it's also very hard to
win over rabbits and cats and dogs and
cows that the plants just aren't quite
attractive enough the students always
get excited about animal science and I'm
in a plant science room so you asked me
some time about my stories about animal
science graduates and their success rate
it has been challenging to have students
walk out with an anal science degree
from here and five years later they're
not an animal science anymore their
career shifted just because of lack of
jobs I don't have many plant science
folks I can say that about the plant
science folks just launched into a
career very very quickly so that's
always a running running gag because
they are so excited about the animals
and the plants are just like yeah
they're there that we landscaping I can
have so much fun with that and the
greenhouses are continuing to grow so
it's part of the process but we have to
get a little more of that background and
turf grass is always a lot of fun to
talk about because you can pull in golf
and some individuals get really excited
about golf besides Frank
so planets so I do think that plant
science continues has more room to grow
simply because the animal science is
ahead of us our certification pathway
right now there are two I see if in
college one is the one I work with
directly SUNY Oswego has an online one
that they've had for long period of time
and then in fall of 2020 with a little
bit of luck and guy look that the State
Education Group does their homework
effectively Empire State College will
bring another one online basically
modeling what we do with Cornell with
Ithaca College but they're gonna have a
hybrid system so some of it'll be online
and some of them be in face-to-face
because at the end of the day we are
we're continuing on the trend of twelve
to thirty new programs a year and right
now I'm graduating I've got seven in
Ithaca you probably have three or four
coming out of a sweet girl so a lot of
about ten and if you build in
retirements as well we're going to be
short five to six teachers easily per
year for the next foreseeable future
then the good news is I got more and
more advisees this year is freshmen true
of AG science candidates so will them
already have this on the radar so that
the momentum is already shifting to the
point where they come in knowing the
salaries you starting to increase if you
looked at that video shows all the crazy
stuff they did so as long as their game
for a lot of crazy ideas across the
whole spectrum it's a it's an awesome
career to do for at least ten or fifteen
years so we're hoping that continues in
trend different sources that pulled from
the national organization I mentioned
the council for their standards as if
they really is a great job of pulling
together resources for the educators as
well and then the Harvard study is a
great is a really interesting read it's
as well and with that I will open it up
to any questions or issues or if it's
something totally out in left field or
hopefully it's not left field anymore
got a slightly better idea the AG
education pathway that hopefully will
start as it has been but continues to
grow in feeding students walking
yeah so much of your presentation
focused on education for training
students to go into colleges so yeah
what is being done for not college
anchors because there are many careers
in agriculture especially so the
question was the the primary discussion
was for college driven careers and what
about the careers that don't require a
college degree especially specifically
in agriculture and that would be a fun
coffee conversation because my
experiences even the the barring just
basic labor there's a little bit of
advanced learning that has to happen
somewhere in the process it might not be
a two-year degree but it's going to be
continual growth of learning there is a
certain percentage that when the work
experience the SAE piece a lot of the
students especially come out of the
Midwest dive right into the program
they'll they'll graduate high school
with basically leasing 1,500 acres from
their parents they bought some equipment
they dive into a continual growth of
their process the biggest one I've seen
in New York or landscapers they'll start
a small group program and grow into an
old fledged business as they transition
out of high school it's not it's still a
fairly small percentage of the students
we work with but that SCE work
experience piece is totally driven
towards getting all the pieces they need
so that if they're ready they can dive
right into a full-fledged work
experience I've just I just caution in
those discussions with students as well
there's always going to be some extra
piece of education even if it's a year
of apprenticeship or a two-year college
that seems to put them in a much
stronger position may not be a four-year
degree but at least a two-year degree to
launch steeper into the salary range but
it's a good question because I didn't
you're right I didn't specifically
highlight that it is working from the
time you graduate high school or go on
into college so there is definitely an
emphasis in that work experience piece
it's just one that a lot I've had
several students while I was teaching
that I never thought they could go to
school and once what they realize is a
two-year
is very obtainable and they've done
really say it so I could tell some great
stories about ones I've had awesome
careers actually one did a 15 years
spent in hardscaping they didn't touch
plants he said all a prep work up and
then a Regional School in New Jersey
came and taught and hired him to teach
because he's been so successful in
business he had a two-year degree out of
Cobleskill never thought he'd go to high
school but never go to college my
principal agreed he never would have
gone to college except that we got him
hooked and he was excited about it and
he found he could achieve the challenge
so it's a really good question that that
spectrum is built into that discussion
but more and more of them are at least
getting a year worth of college before
they launch yeah awesome question but so
the college takes 10% of our incoming
class have this experience they have
data on other students perform verses
that would be a good that is a question
I should ask yeah I think it's a good
question I should nudge them about
because I'm not sure they're capture
exiting is there data exiting is very
strong it would be really great to be
able to match that back up because they
do have it for incoming I have to ask
I can nudge a couple folks to see if
it's on the radar I've not asked that
the exit end if they track where people
are going that's a that would be a great
thing to do to show strength I mean it's
yeah that's a great idea
we must know intuitively that yeah well
and they because they tend to write they
tend to be very strong in their their
personal identity and getting ready to
launch into a career what I find are the
ones that are successful of a very
refined focus for when they write their
applications essays those that write
very general application essays aren't
going to get in a door because it's too
competitive yeah but I like that idea I
also go back and uh just a couple folks
in the central office say hey what about
some data collection we know we've got
the data coming in do we have any data
come out good idea we just you had a
question yeah is there resources
available to connect
FFA students or graduate students with
arms because I know there's a lot of
farms that have issues with um
hiring people that are interested in
farming or entertaining them yeah so
there wit is there something that exists
that connects the two of them well it
would be a community by community basis
I mean in the community itself they're
typically attached to an advisory board
and that advisory board is made up of
those farms and and community members
it'll be a farm it'll be the the in some
cases it'll be a dairy producer
sometimes it'll be a greenhouse operator
plus equipment dealer as part of that
advisory but it doesn't help the solute
that doesn't solve the problem that that
well because even given that they're
still struggling to have students that
want to channel in into that level of
work experience so the it really is a
community case-by-case so the teachers
are very familiar with the producers in
the area they have to be that's part of
what keeps them the program alive and
surviving but that doesn't how it's not
going to necessarily help the labor that
much the the group I worked with in
western New York
it was the Wyoming County so number one
dairy county in the state they didn't
want me teaching production dairy they
felt that it was it was taking too many
steps back they said teach everything
else don't worry about the production
dairy type stuff just get him to go to
college they didn't even want to talk
about the labor stuff they were already
to that point they were using immigrant
success exclusively and really didn't
feel that they wanted to try to bring
because this was the sons and daughters
of the community members and they're
like some of them ended up going to
Cobleskill in Cornell and having success
but a lot of them didn't want that just
labor discussion it's a very it was a
very intriguing perspective but when I
got there I'm like okay we can go and do
dairy and do it oh don't do that quite
so much we don't because it was hard to
compete I had a sixty five horsepower
tractor and they're running 300
horsepower tractors their kids weren't
doing the work either because it was too
big so it's a different dialogue I have
more I had better luck in Cortland where
Main Street Farms is a small fairly
decent-sized vegetable operation and the
farms are lot smaller that discussion is
a little more integrated so there's
actually some nice work experience
programs happening because the community
is a good fit for that yeah but it is
very much community by community basis
it's not something that's that's
statewide
yeah good question because that's a
challenging question I noticed that in
the images that you showed of FFA
members virtually all of them were white
as you lose as FFA roots or into urban
programs are you starting to see more
racial diversity so our largest program
in New York State is in Queens largest
have a numbers and largest number of
teachers they've got feet to 10 teachers
on board it's a 500 student program
99.8% non-caucasian so it's it's Latinos
blacks all different spectrums very very
few Caucasian individuals and so that's
the trend of a trend the growth in the
urban areas is slow but that's a lot of
time because the teachers right now are
coming out of rural experiences we're
trying to recruit I did have one young
man just finished from John Bowne just
finished the degrees now teaching in
John Bowne so that's going to be the
next hurdle we're working with is how do
we recruit an urban based workforce to
go back into that area that have the
agricultural spectrum because that
diversity is there for sure but we're
actually the other place I've got a they
just started a charter school in
Syracuse on 10th it's an agricultural
basis and that one is very difficultly
diverse and they're having a great
they're really having some great success
and growth from as they add each grade
it's it's agriculturally driven it's a
very mixed teaching cultural base as
well and I think that's that's the
moving trend the primary reason you see
this is the Midwest is still extremely
lack of diversity across the Midwestern
states and that's a large portion of our
membership is Oklahoma Texas Georgia
it's very hard and the urban
environments the urban centers are still
not really strong yet yeah good question
and that's one the FFA is very aware of
what we're trying to continue to grow in
our next growth phases in the urban
areas yeah that's our projection final
questions
if sources for a program what would you
recommend how would you recommend that
they integrate those things are there Oh
ever beat the question so the question
was if the if the school districts it is
limited on funding really isn't a
position I have a full-time a 'grill
program how do you integrate the process
and the within the school systems what
happens quite a bit is long distance
learning or will have I've got a couple
schools that will actually remotely feed
out to three or four neighboring schools
they have a joint FFA so at night
they'll they'll come together for
meetings once a month and that advisor
oversees three or four different schools
and in some cases even in locally in
Tully
they'll bus students from one school
into Tully for participation
participating in the event that event as
well I mean you can the other the other
group I didn't specifically talk about
but the other thing to do is make sure
you've got a strong 4-h because the 4-h
is community driven and really has a lot
of the same intersecting interests so in
some cases the 4-h can take over that
role if the community if the school
system just doesn't have a resources but
we have had a lot of success with
partnering and sharing of teachers and
facilities across a couple different
schools yeah that's a good question it's
one we continue to wrestle with the nice
thing is right now there seems to be a
because I've even got Cincinnatus is one
of the smallest schools I've ever run
into and the superintendent has found
resources he's ready to go next year
he's like okay we've had a couple
retirements we've been kind of
repurposing our staffing and he's
created cuz a lot of these teachers are
also dual certified in biology so
they'll also help the court teach the
core academic classes while they're
teaching some agriculture classes good
very good question this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu